for many children logging on to the
internet is the first thing they do in
the morning
88 percent of german children go online
every
day a smartphone is a game console tv
music player and communications device
all-in-one
in my class we all use a class chat app
and if i wasn't on it i'd miss out on
everything like if i forgot my homework
i can't really imagine what i'd do
without my smartphone
in most families children are more
computer savvy than their parents
hard-working moms and dads can hardly
keep up with the newest trends
it requires so much energy to always
have to check to see what they're doing
to have that feeling i need to know what
they're up to
it's especially hard to supervise older
children for teenagers with a smartphone
sex and violence are always just a few
clicks away
many young adults post their own videos
online before thinking about the
long-term consequences
it can start out innocently enough a
young person sends a selfie to a friend
but a photo sometimes falls into the
wrong hands
one in three teenagers has experienced
cyber bullying
i know someone who took a photo of
herself in a bikini then on a class trip
someone stole her smartphone and sent
the photo to all of her contacts
personal photos unintentionally posted
for all the world to see cyber bullies
use the internet to publicly humiliate
their victims
there was a boy in my school and he got
bullied because he smelled bad
there are a lot of photos of him posted
online with the word stinker written
underneath
experts take cyber mobbing seriously but
it can be difficult to protect a child
from vicious cyber attacks
you should deal with the issue right
away
tell the teacher if necessary if it gets
really bad if it's posted on facebook or
twitter
then you should have the post removed
and maybe call the police
another problematic issue violent video
games
many parents don't want their kids
exposed to them but age restrictions are
hard to enforce most kids find ways to
download their favorite games
youth protection programs can help
parents safeguard their children
they can download programs like the
kidsafe browser or k9 the applications
work on most tablets and smartphones
they filter out internet content not
deemed age appropriate
the software automatically installs a
list of prohibited and approved websites
the programs also warn users against
unsolicited subscriptions and illegal
downloads parents should also turn off
so-called download helper programs
but so far there is still no way to make
the internet completely kid safe experts
say a costly mistake could teach a child
an important life
in lesson one has to understand that if
you're unlucky one wrong mouse click can
cost mom or dad or yourself a lot of
money getting misled on the internet can
be a good learning experience
children with smartphones also run the
risk of spending too much time online
german children spend around three hours
a day surfing the web
on weekends it's sometimes even longer
german researchers developed the app
mental to help users keep track of their
internet use
the app tells me i accessed my
smartphone 97 times yesterday i sent
zero text messages made zero phone calls
but i spent over six hours online
that's crazy
shift says time to put down your
smartphone